>> THE WORLD IS A COMPLETE
BUMMER RIGHT NOW.
AND HERE AT E! WE KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES YOU JUST HAVE TO BE
LIKE, "BUUUUH."
SO TURN YOUR BRAIN OFF WITH OUR
NEW LINE-UP OF FALL PROGRAMMING.
FIRST, WE'RE CELEBRATING
10 YEARS OF THE KARDASHIAN
DYNASTY WITH OUR NEW SERIES,
"KENDALL'S MODEL HOUSE."
TUNE IN AS KENDALL JENNER AND
SUPERMODEL SISTERS, BELLA AND
GIGI HADID COMPLAIN AROUND A
HUGE BOWL OF FRUIT.
>> I'M UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE.
>> SO MUCH PRESSURE.
>> YOU ARE PRETTIER THAN ME.
>> NO WAY.
>> YOU ARE SO MUCH PRETTIER THAN
ME.
>> WHICH ONE AM I?
>> ALEXA?
>> YOU ARE KENDALL JENNER.
>> WHAT?
NOT EVERYTHING CAN BE GOOD NEWS.
SO IF YOU WANT TO FEEL
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING, WATCH "DOWN
HOME WITH BLAKE AND GWYNN"
TUESDAYS AT 9:30.
THEY ARE JUST LIKE US.
>> I LOVE YOU, GIRL.
>> I LOVE YOU, TOO.
GO HIGH.
I LOVE YOU -- YOU KNOW WHAT,
WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON IT.
>> BE SURE TO CATCH BLAKE AND
GWYNN IN THE RIVETING SEASON
FINALE.
LET'S BE REAL.
MOST OF THESE SHOWS ARE JUST
PEOPLE LOOKING AT THEIR PHONES.
YOU'D WATCH THAT FOR 20 MINUTES.
AND THAT'S OKAY.
YOU KNOW THE MOMENTS ON THE
KARDASHIANS WHERE KANYE CLEARLY
DOESN'T WANT TO BE ON CAMERA?
NOW THERE'S A SHOW THAT'S JUST
THAT.
IT'S "WHERE'S KANYE?"
HE'S HANGING BACK BECAUSE HE IS
SHY OR HE DOESN'T WANT TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SHOW.
"WHERE IS KANYE?"
THEN WEDNESDAYS AT 10:15, GET
LOST IN "KENDALL'S WORLD."
>> HELLO?
>> AS KENDALL JENNER LITERALLY
GETS LOST IN HER OWN HOUSE.
>> HELLO?
>> THE HOUSE IS SO BIG AND
EMPTY.
AND SHE'S ONLY THERE TWO WEEKS
OUT OF THE YEAR.
>> IS THIS THE BATHROOM?
DAMN, CLOSET AGAIN.
>> BUT HEY, THAT'S "KENDALL'S
WORLD."
THURSDAYS AT 10:00.
BACKGROUND ACTORS OF RIVERDALE.
THEN THERE'RE BOSSES, HOES, AND
TWINS ON "POWERFUL SLUTS OF
MIAMI."
AND YOU LOVE HER ON "FASHION
POLICE."
NOW REALITY STAR NENE LEAKES HAS
HER OWN SHOW.
>> I WAS ON BRAVO.
NOW I'M ON E!
I'M EVERYWHERE, BITCH.
I HATE THAT.
>> NENE LEAKES IS "I HATE THAT."
>> ROUND OUT THE WEEK WITH
SPECIAL EPISODES OF "KENDALL'S
WORLD."
THAT'S RIGHT, SHE'S STILL LOST,
BUT SHE FOUND A COMFY CLOSET TO
HUNKER DOWN IN.
>>> OH, YAY.
>> WHERE IS GIGI?
SHE DIDN'T MAKE IT.
DID YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM IN
HERE?
>> "KENDALL'S WORLD" FRIDAYS AT
9, 9:30, 10, 10:30 AND SO ON
FOREVER.
ONLY ON E!
YOU WANT THIS!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪